it is day two of the biggest manhunt hey
state prison has ever seen after a long
night patrolling the area there's still
no sign of Michael tweedle or Johnny
Mack Brown the clock is ticking to find
the fugitives before they find their way
out of the perimeter even more important
is capturing them before they become
desperate and even more dangerous boy
sir how you doing
Commissioner James Donald is the
Department of Corrections top authority
it's just arrived from Atlanta and has
brought with him some tough questions
okay well that's just getting it on
Italian lines gonna start we had our
regular routine your call that's one to
see two inmates are on the yard to start
with then at 10 20 30 for P notify
control that there were sheets and
blankets on the fence at that time
because identify the two inmates were
missing at 11:45 miss jakey's arrived
and took over the operation based on our
tracking they left here in a
southeasterly direction
work down to the river they crossed then
went about 50 yards cross back they did
that four times back and forth until
they got up north of us and then the dog
still caught up with a track dogs then
tracked em to where the inmates lay down
the inmates we felt laid down at that
point when that helicopter got over they
got in a very heavy canopy area we can
see the indention on the ground we can
see blood on the ground where the
inmates lay
Commissioner myself in investigator
miner arrived on scene and we secured
the area that of course the cell was
already secured we did take photographs
we cannot reveal the specifics of the
escape but it's clear that tweedle and
brown used makeshift tools to scale the
fences these are not not both armed
robbers I am a little bit of concern
about the history of John Knight Brown
he's a scary fella and we want to make
sure that we get him back in control
as soon as possible our basic and most
fun little mission is protect public and
these are my guys I want back I want you
to take that person 1 and deputy what
all right
behind the command center inmates have
been on lockdown since the incident and
they hold a completely different
perspective well as soon as they escaped
today the emergency count you know and
everything was real real tight you know
and then they had zero movement around
the compound there was a lot of shock at
who it was you know it's it's two older
fellows it's not who you would expect
the mood was you know excited and
encouraged and inspired and you know
whatever around some people are walking
around and you could like see it in
their faces you're not supposed to be
escape from this camp you know I can't
say I pray for him now saying but but
you know deep down inside here yeah I
hope these dudes do get away then never
find that's our team on that plane you
know I might think I call we lose so
yeah we we'd be down most inmates think
of escaping but a life on the run is too
harsh and the chance of getting caught
is too high on the chain gang Escape is
an extreme dreamt by many but attempted
by few